i did
so many pilots there was a thing i would
do pilots that they would go we want
bird to be burnt and that was the mantra
and then when they got that version of
bert it was too much
and so my wife used to say like
they they think they're ordering a spicy
salmon when they get burped being burnt
what they're getting is a turducken it's
a lot more complicated
so like we had we had a show he's got
two daughters by the way
oh yeah we had a show one time uh where
tom segura this is before tom's girl was
tom's girl right right he was just my
buddy i got a show on on
comedy central where i would take people
home after they're drunk on a drunk bus
they'd play a game show drunk and they'd
win money right the first thing they did
is they blow into a blood alcohol thing
and whatever they blew we'd added 100 to
it and that's what they started their
thing with so we didn't realize we were
just we were
setting people up to go we'd blow and
they go hold on give me a minute i'll go
into the bar and get get it higher
because they were getting 100 for every
point they go higher yes and we had
people come in
i'm talking blackout drunk
and my favorite and there's a million
i mean people said the most regrettable
regrettable things that you could ever
imagine we we had
we had uh a dude and a girl on their
like third date and were like have you
ever blown have you ever had sex with an
animal and he goes i blew a squirrel
once when i was a kid
and we were like what because it fell
out of a tree and we were like so you
thought
we had three guys we had three guys and
we said
we were doing a game tom segura by the
way tom scooter came in
and fired the head writer he was just
gonna be an assistant fired the head
writer and took over the entire writing
so the writing was in tom segura's
sensibility with my voice
it was the funniest he played a game
called uh smash or pass or no no it was
uh a liquor stick it we put a
a picture of this is so politically
incorrect right now i understand that
there's a picture of a female celebrity
and you had to guess were they a lesbian
or were they straight and so and we had
these two mexican guys in there and they
were just like i have no [ __ ] i don't
know any of these guys people are then
we bring three dudes and one of them one
of the ones comes up is jamie lee curtis
who it's it's been rumored
was was born both right right so we go
look at her stick it and it's jamie
curtis and the guy goes stick it my dad
[ __ ] her
so we're like what and he goes yeah i go
for an extra 300 get your dad on the
phone and find out if she was born a man
he's like
okay so he calls his dad it was like it
was the most out of control
show you could ever ever ever where is
this show
so zoe friedman uh they
they zoe freeman told me this
uh
they played it and it was the funniest
[ __ ] pilot you've ever seen i mean
i'd go that's for comedy central before
comedy center i go hey ladies for a
hundred dollars one of my favorite
things is lipstick and
and the girl goes you want me to put it
on her with my tits and we're like
that's how for a hundred dollars please
do that and then they just do it you're
like here's a hundred dollars i mean
it was such a great great great show and
so they went
last they do all their upfronts to do
all their shows they're gonna
potentially put on the air
and uh they pour a shot at tequila and
they're like let's watch the best show
we have coming out this year
uh and they put it on and um
and everyone's like that's literally
they're like what let's order 30
episodes it is perfect and their ad
sales guy is like i cannot sell that and
they're like what he goes who the [ __ ]
do you think is going to put advertising
and it's just like it's the most
i mean
it was the most irreverent show you
could ever hope to watch isn't that what
comedy central should be though
uh it should yeah uh yeah it should be
but i think that i think at the time
they were winning with like niche you
know alternative comic sketch shows like
the dimitri martins and and uh and amy
schumer's and that was what was winning
for them and something like this was it
was very low bro it was me and some sort
of sensibility and it was that it was so
good
[Music]
you